welcome to this video playing am Cooper
here crappy hmm don't know and I always
forget Charlie cop Charlie couple no
don't know this guy I have played a play
to me for you three me yeah this is one
of those ancient lines at the English
hmm this should before as a wolf you
should be sadness animals all right 95 s
son okay come on keep it simple I think
this is the possible way to play so we
have a quick opening up of the position
should i play can i play something like
94 and then take okay let's let's try
that maybe this is too ambitious but
let's let them experiment me my idea was
to take here and play night before and
then did you five maybe night before
let's let's try that but what what am I
actually playing on yeah after this I
have 95 I am Not sure that it is good
but it's at least funny but maybe d5a
stir the batter move yeah d 52 to open
things up if he goes iii.airplane 95
Louis is 93 I know no he can play three
this was stupid but on a three I can't
play 96 okay this is not not too
terrible what I'm trying to do is
somehow use my slightly very slightly
better development yeah before I was
thinking I can play Knight c5 queen bee
493 winning the queen but the Queen on
before of course simply protected so it
is a complete complete nonsense um yeah
I was thinking about c5 though maybe c5
counter-attacking takes before takes d4
and this is probably not too bad but
okay
who knows
now probably can just kiss on I don't
know taking taking could be could be
tricky
hmm
yeah the the the bad thing is i actually
have sector porn for this for this
strange stuff and this is really really
questionable they are probably taking
what's bad as well yeah just upon down
for basically nothing hmm yeah probably
i need some attacking miracle on the
Kings side but the heck did i do there
yeah this was all very loose very loose
plane with d5 and c5 but maybe i should
i shouldn't take only 3 this was stupid
it really was speeding up oh wow really
wait wait wait wait not let's let's just
consider I've got various tick trixia 92
taking a 92
yeah I can do that the Queen hangs the
rook Hanks and the bishop hangs so if
he's playing Queen a for taking the rook
I can take the bishop so taking on a
seven was probably a lemon well just
just win win the exchange now but okay I
was material down before it's not it's
not so easy probably
23 I know probably needs to protect the
vision
Quincy too okay but what is the point I
other the medium the latest the point
made this often a good point Wow but ok
ok ok is there some way to to play this
aggressively like with some tactic I
don't think so I mean it's not necessary
i can i can just drop back and don't
think this is too bad they still there
ok
the Queen safely protects some eight now
my background is really weak sup always
cause for concern now text III be too
okay keep it simple okay there's
something better
this was probably the otic why did I do
that just Bishop d7 as much easier
check okay he's hoping for my hoping to
exploit the time situation so just just
a piece i get the beep on check step
full-time morning be boys check check
check
jan 9 seconds is not not too much check
check
check check check
I can take five unfortunately but this
look each one check check okay game
drawn ah just a draw yeah rook air-five
yeah okay I didn't have any time any
time left and of course it's um it's
very easy with just just a bit of time
but ok and it is even major rock a tu as
medium yeah I felt there should be a
maid but I didn't of course I couldn't
couldn't calculate anymore with three
seconds rookie to as a maid and at the
rook is hanging so I knew ok rock move
it must be but i didn't i didn't spot
the right the right one and yeah he ok i
wanted i wanted to draw this is still
win with the force made the computer
sees this easily yeah i really should
should make that 30 seconds was rather
or even this is rather a lot to win this
alright thanks for watching